yup the house I built yeah it's me this
mean this is the house I built now you
up in here are you trying to get it you
try to get it in I rearranged some uh
some records in the books
definitely a might rush coming no issue
it was was definitely challenge Gary
Payton the second flying inside with the
left hand
hammer you want your home you want home
don't try to be like me or better than
me
be you be yourself and he's done that in
two years right back to GP to attach the
bastard lays it up
to take it away from Jacobs and kick it
back to tickle I packed it aggressively
like my father always told me to do in a
game you know it turned out for the best
you know don't be surprised when you see
that - behind that name what do you
think about it oh it's like here and pay
right what's your the gear thing hey
don't change don't change me because I'm
talking about it a go change me and
imagine personalities I don't try to
think about how he was when he was here
I was gonna be my own person gp2 steps
into a three and head wait listen let's
play for something we all shoot we're
gonna play uh we don't play Peyton yep
PAYG Oh in all right now you wanna try
to shoot a mid-range I'm sure getting my
rhythm spot man you trying to get you
ready dude I like it when you get it up
yep see you later hey yeah that's B
that's B what you like playing in France
my father started here me get back it's
interesting
no I dunno what I'm gonna get with some
games that you don't know what he's
gonna get oh that's a terrible cost
buddy trying to do this
krytus game so weak because of y'all who
is in here we should sell this out
14,000 then we'd be going crazy we do
now we going live I'll get it yeah yeah
yeah you get it is y'all got it back
cranky I go in there and them fans are
doing the same thing and they're rocking
for my son decide where they was rocking
for me that's a good feeling
it makes me feel like I'm back there on
the floor and then especially seeing my
son it's like I'm there now I'm a baby
gee you got to hold it baby I want that
guy said I'm a banking gee that's what I
do
UK UK he can't free throws look at that
oh I told you PA yo nowadays Oh
everybody my father and trash talking
the worst part about it is he can back
it up one hand can you do what your
right yeah all right
okay come on me hurry up hurry up
he can't do a little bit that's it's
horrible that's horrible I definitely
had the gene I can deathly trash-talk
it's just I just do it probably slicker
way oh we had that strength okay he went
from grown man to old man with me I wish
he did have a more dog any but I have
accepted my son man
just write that way looted belly what
I'm going to do like but oh no Duncan
here huh did you see that bow I can't
get nothing my freshman and sophomore
year in high school I didn t back well
seriously he sat me down that summer and
really explained to me that I was gonna
have to hit my way to school if I want
to go to school week three I just made a
decision that I wanted to make
that's why my full-time job but me being
tough on you look what it did it paid
off in a major mindset a little
different now you work give you look at
your body your children but we come to
possible all-american you the finalists
for the play up best point guard in the
country you plan probably get drafted in
June hopefully soon so shoot it paid off
for you that ain't gonna work what a
step back tomorrow taught me that one my
dad is one of the greatest to ever play
the game I think I definitely you know
got out of his shadow growing up his
huge shoes to fill and I didn't know how
to react to it one of the main reasons
why I got out of it was just being
myself in a zone a matchup with gp2
pulling up right elbow 16-foot jumper is
perfect and I feel really happy for my
son because he took a long road to get
here I hope he just keep working and
keep working and become a good
basketball player and staying here
here comes Payton hits first bucket
coming up
you'll never beat me 101 never God never
ever not until I get about 70 and I'm
I'm in a wheelchair or something like
that he can't finish the deal though
did you write here
right what about that bit when we're
behind he's over he want one yeah we
bought Tommy Windsong worried about
nothing I got the best of them today and
I think I think he's not gonna play
anymore because he knows now I can I can
I can compete with him
I got confidence I can I ain't told you
I'm real proud of proud of you man
no you lot man you know I said so that
we don't do it that's level